[Música]
a senhora
e senhor a poesia coisa que vem senhora
mas raramente sem dores
as verdades que lhes direi agora são
cinco vitórias e repletas de horrores
pois vocês sabem não sabe aqueles que
sentem fome por horas não distinguem as
trocas e não negam amores crianças são
crianças mundo afora onde fores sem
advertência
as crianças não são crianças
eles roubam a inocentes
tal
montaria uma história de uma menina que
renasceu que tem despedaçado rosas e
visto beleza na crueza da vida de
espíritas em grandes realizações
roteiros ou movimentações de câmera
a vida é mais como uma câmera tremida
que levamos nas mãos balanços prêmio e
sem muita organização a 1 e baixos não
independente singular e subjetivo ou
particular mas compartilhado contaria
essa história a história de uma menina
que está crescendo o que está se vendo
no reflexo do yashi elevada um outro
riacho que é levado a um rio que se
junta a outro rio e deságua quem sabe
numa cachoeira fortaleza frágil
inimaginável onde a gota sozinha
acaricia e o corpo d'água junto à barra
relaxe as coisas da vida são como a
própria vida
contaria essa história se não fosse bobo
fita e ser aumente a contagem
outra história uma história de plurais
que nos corpos ingênuos diariamente
corporificadas materializadas vendidos
ou trocados por quaisquer coisas da vida
alimento na barriga do estômago para as
vísceras nada mal a 2 noites 8 e nem 18
elas têm os 400 não dou conta das
necessidades nascidas antes do g8 e os
centenas de mundos e tão vítimas de um
outro mundo sujo se lambuzam as delícias
em troca de iniciou os biscoitos bala e
pipoca desejo singelo de crianças
o óleo que ilumina casa à beira de um
decisivos da vida é pouco kalume a vida
dessa gente condenada sofrida não
pergunta onde está deus nos estados onde
está amanda incondicionalmente todos os
envolvidos na pergunta é onde está você
a história que lhes conto não é fábula e
os senhores bem sabem que a beleza é
essencial para a vida o belo é agradável
é convidativo é gentil e amável
a beleza de não ser tratada pela
minissérie a beleza de se ter mais
extremamente mais que uma porção de
portarias porcarias tão necessárias à
beleza
o mundo é sutil é tossan por vezes de
detalhes supérfluos mas necessária
a beleza de uma com chegou de um leito
de um abrigo um aplico de um banquete
ele contaria a história senhores
histórias e mais histórias sul uma
contadora delas uma feitoria delas todas
comoveram a todos mas o que seriam das
histórias esquecidas se permanecessem no
escuro oralidades mortas assassinadas em
marcha o nebre silenciar
[Música]
preciso descansar o nosso igual para mim
lembrou avançadas a atividade da vida
[Música]
hoje eu tenho
o mundo olha que graça
mas a 1989 além disso foi o gabinete de
existência de novas enzimas mentions
estava na garrafa
com isto não vai ficar para amanhã
amanhã
a briga só aqueles olhos parou enquanto
o rácio
[Aplausos]
[Música]
repercute na venda
o time potiguar
[Música]
foi isso
mal
mesmo assim a última
é preciso primeiro
tá bom
[Música]
[Aplausos]